alexander löhr ist mir zugeschaltet er
ist vorsitzender der stadt
schülervertretung in münchen und
natürlich das thema schule ist präsent
sie sind dafür dass das abi dass die abi
prüfungen stattfinden wenn es die
umstände zulassen
nun wird darüber geredet wie man die
schulen wieder aufmachen könnte masken
abstand kleine gruppen viel händewaschen
viel hygiene wird da genannt von der
politik für mich als jemand der die
zustände in berliner schulen kennt
klingt das fast ein bisschen ironisch
wie sind denn die hygienischen zustände
in münchen in den schulen in einigen
schulen gibt es natürlich das infektion
spender mit desinfektionsmittel und
natürlich kann man es regelmäßig die
hände waschen aber mit warmem wasser ist
das meist nicht möglich
wir haben meist auch nur kaltes wasser
zur verfügung und ich gestalte sich das
noch ganz schwierig weil die massen an
das funktioniert natürlich auch gegeben
sein müssten wenn meine schule wieder
auch machen möchte um sicherheit um die
sicherheit und die handschaltung risiko
zu minimieren und aus ihrer sicht was
wäre denn jetzt das beste vorgehen
alle schulen öffnen nur für die
jahrgänge die prüfungen haben
also ich persönlich bin erst mal dafür
natürlich müssen wir uns nach den
vorgaben der politik halten und das
natürlich sicherheit da die gesundheit
ist herr oberster stelle
und sollte es möglich sein einen
unterrichtsbetrieb in kleinem maße
wieder herzustellen dann erstmal für die
abschlussklassen wir sind der meinung
die abschlussklasse hat priorität
es ist wichtig dass jeder sein abschluss
machen kein sein abitur mit der reife
oder ähnliches das dass wir voll
geschrieben werden kann
das hat oberste priorität und das hat
mir dafür sind weil die abschlussklassen
zunächst erstmal mit schule geben können
also erst einmal die abschlussklassen
damit das abi damit prüfungen
geschrieben werden können alexander löhr
vorsitzender der stadt schülervertretung
in münchen ganz herzlichen dank und sie
schauen sich ja auch ganz gespannt heute
nach
berlin dankeschön